- Kaley and I were just talking
about the strength of
having female friendships.
Have you always found that's like really
good for you and healthy for you as well?
- Are you gonna cry? Are we both
gonna cry all over again?
- We're both gonna cry. Okay,
don't ruin our makeup Kaley Cuoco.
- I know, it looks so good,
I know, leave it to me.
- Yes, I mean, I think, you know, I,
everyone has difficulties in their lives
and like I'm not super
close with my family,
and I've always found chosen family
to be so exceptionally important.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think, like, as women,
it's just, it's tantamount to anything,
obviously like
relationships are important,
romantic relationships, but I think
female friendship is just, it brings it
to another level. You're
gonna make me cry.
- Is that a tattoo as well on your palm?
- It is a tattoo.
- She's a wild child.
- I am.
- Are these like you drink a lot
and you're like this would be awesome,
get a heart, or is this just like your -
- You don't even have to get me drunk
is the sad part.
Literally if you were like
if you right now were like, "Do you wanna
ditch this and go get a tattoo?"
I'd be like, "Sure, let's go".
- No because I'm addicted to them as well
I have like 20. Like I have so many.
But they're all little small ones.
- Me too.
- Yeah so that's why I was wondering
because a couple of mine were like
"That sounds like a great idea".
- Yeah, yeah. Thankfully, I'm really happy
that I haven't made any
like horrendous decisions.
- Me too. Way to go.
- Yeah, yeah, way to go. Way to go.
- A lot of tattoos, that's nice.
- My husband drunkenly almost got
a pigeon tattooed on
himself and I was like
- Threats of the sky.
- Yeah, there you go. I don't
think I ever told you that.
- "Threats of the sky".
- Just right on your body, that's amazing.
That's cool. That's awesome.